[Música]
con equipo reducido pero entusiasta les
damos la bienvenida a su programa
semanal canadá en las américas café de
radio canadá internacional desde
nuestros nuestros estudios aquí en la
ciudad de montreal en el menú de esta
semana tenemos francofonía tenemos a
cada día tenemos un poco de arte de
ciencia de migración y mucho más así que
no se vayan aquí en el estudio
estamos leonardo gimeno luis laborda
paloma martínez y del otro lado en la
fuera de la cabina están personas que
nos hacen mucha falta porque si no este
programa no saldría al aire pierde el
carburante y benoit gioja muchas gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en los estudios
gracias a todos por allá en la cabina
bueno como decía aquí en el programa
vamos a tener varias varios temas
interesantes como siempre como estar
cansado pero bien cansado porque es
viernes no solamente porque es viver que
has trabajado todo el verano
algo que me está preocupando
por no decir me está dando ciertos
sentimientos de culpa y hasta de agobio
mental a ver qué es serio cuando
nosotros hablamos del clima que lo
hacemos frecuentemente de que nos
quejamos por lo general que hace frío
del infierno y decimos que en invierno
es cansador porque es muy largo porque
las temperaturas son muy exigentes
porque hay poco sol porque evidentemente
el organismo se exige mucho más para
poder hacer frente al medio ambiente con
las bajas temperaturas que hay acá en el
invierno esté maquillo me siento súper
agotado ahora en pleno verano
me falta una semana para las vacaciones
que ella por suerte llega así es bueno
yo antes de que continuamos con los
temas quería de alguna manera mencionar
que a quién radio canadá internacional
esta semana estamos bastante tristes
conmovidos de alguna manera porque una
de nuestras colegas muy queridas carmel
kilkenny falleció esta semana
carmen era alguien maravilloso era
alguien muy profesional
es como ser humano increíble yo no sé
queremos enviar un mensaje a su familia
de parte de todos nosotros si a su
manera carmen nos hizo bien a todos días
ella trabajaba para el equipo inglés de
radio canal internacional digamos que el
contacto con entre los sectores no es
muy asiduo pero a sí mismo era bastante
ha sido su contacto porque él ha
participado mucho y bueno yo en realidad
como webmaster trabajé bastante con ella
así que decir realmente es una pérdida
dolorosa y para el saludo a la familia
y a todos sus seres queridos tiene dos
hijas
así que un saludo un abrazo grande para
todos ellos en esta parte inevitable de
la vida
la recordamos con mucho cariño y carmen
además alguien que siempre le interesó
mucho la cuestión de los inmigrantes
porque ella venía de una familia de
inmigrantes inmigrantes irlandeses en
canadá entonces bueno un abrazo entonces
para la familia y estamos aquí pensando
en ella y pensamos en ella todo este
todos estos días desde que supimos de su
fallecimiento bueno en el programa de
hoy como decíamos vamos a hablar de
varias cosas pero me gusta que
comenzáramos con la fiesta de los acadia
nos el 15 de agosto de alguna manera
explicar qué es una cadena sí claro
claro tengo toda la información sobre
los acadia nos son todos aquellos que
pertenecen a un grupo étnico y cultural
bien distinto bien único y que tiene una
lengua común que es el francés viven
principalmente en tres provincias
canadienses en nuevo brunswick en la
isla del príncipe eduardo y en nueva
escocia aunque también hay acá
en la provincia de québec entonces todo
en la región este del país en la que
conocemos como la región de las
marítimas y también hay algunos que se
instalaron en maine pero hay otros que
son descendientes de acadia nos que
viven en en luisiana en eeuu en el sur
que son digamos los descendientes de
aquellos que fueron deportados desde
canadá hacia el sur porque hablaban
francés entonces de alguna manera es una
celebración de la lengua francesa de la
cultura acá diana y de los acá dientes
acadia no so acá dientes creo que sí
distinto vistos y de la región de a cada
día que está como decíamos en esas tres
provincias canadienses y bueno en el
marco de las celebraciones de los acadia
nos se lleva a cabo el congreso nacional
acadia no y dentro de él una reunión de
red de una red de ciudades francófonas
de américa y un encuentro de jóvenes en
estas ciudades francófonas de las
américas y ustedes no tal vez no se lo
imaginaban pero buenos aires
y méxico son ciudades francófonos de las
américas
que hablan francés en toda argentina
alianza francesa también está hay muchos
descendientes de francés
no solamente es decir que en la
educación pública en la argentina hasta
creo yo los años 50 o por lo menos si
problema solución 50 si no los comienzos
de los 60 en la lengua francesa era una
de las lenguas enseñadas incluso en el
sistema público de enseñanza y era una
de las lenguas mayoritarias a partir de
los 60 comienza a ser suplantada por el
inglés y hoy en día hay todavía
institutos que enseñan el francés e
inclusive cuando uno hace el
bachillerato en comercial si no la vamos
con exactamente con la denominación
ahora de la escuela que no es comercial
la escuela secundaria que no es
comercial
[Música]
francés es una de las lenguas que se
enseñan allí se da tres años inglés y
dos años francés que nosotros tuvimos yo
tuve eso por ejemplo de youtube en
realidad es del primer año del
secundario hasta quinto tuve inglés y
primero segundo tercero tenía francés
y hay mucha gente que todavía lo habla y
más allá de que muchos hoy está entre
unos áreas se sienten franceses y hablan
de la arquitectura francesa que es
verdad que en algunos barrios de buenos
aires- efectivamente pero bueno bueno
entonces esta red esta reunión de la red
de ciudades francófonas de las américas
es organizada por el pse son son de la
francophonie de sameji o el centro de la
francofonía de las américas y están
reunidos justamente en montón en dentro
del marco de las celebraciones del
acadia nos varios jóvenes y varias
personas entre otros un mexicano y un
argentino que tenemos por
teleconferencia están por ahí en manuel
alberto videla y carlos adrián zúñiga
gonzález ambos profesores de francés en
sus respectivas ciudades como están
y puedo darle
pues qué tal carlos a
ustedes son como decía yo ambos
profesores de francés en sus ciudades
respectivas carlos en mexico y emanuel
en argentina entonces yo me quedé y me
preguntaba cómo dos jóvenes de ciudades
hispano zonas de lengua spain de lengua
española llegaron a interesarse y además
convertirse en expertos en profesores de
francés en sus ciudades respectivas
carlos
en méxico allí
él
bueno
[Música]
carlos que voy a interrumpir porque
sabes que no estamos entendiendo bien lo
que está pasando allí como un problema
con la transmisión de sonora porque la
imagen es perfecta pero el sonido queda
un poco deja un poco de vez que desear
entonces yo creo que van a ver nuestros
colegas de la técnica si pueden hacer
algo al respecto sino yo creo que
podemos seguir un poco hablando de los
siguientes temas de la semana tenemos
otros de hecho hicimos algo que hicimos
la semana pasada y que vamos a volver a
hacer esta semana que es presentar
algunas fotos de verano porque bueno de
verano de lo que el verdad
angustiado porque si bien son mucho
calor y estado bastante lindo el sábado
pasado fui a jugar mi partido dominical
de fútbol y los gansos llegaron y
arrancaron no nos están moviendo
no se van no se van todavía pero se
están moviendo y eso implica que están
buscando bases como para emprender el
viaje diciendo los gansos gansos canadá
gusto
pero se están moviendo si yo los vi en
los parques cercanos a mí a mi casa que
en realidad no es una zona para nada
silvestre es en medio de la ciudad de
montreal y ya estaban en un parque
cercanísimo entonces creo que
efectivamente comienzan y están haciendo
las compras no uno cuando se va de viaje
va a buscar los regalos que buscan los
mejores lugares para comprarnos los
víveres terminando de comer lo que quede
por ahí exacto entre estos muchachos
están haciendo lo mismo y eso a mí me
angustia porque implica que prontamente
no van
bueno lo que se verá no lo podemos
relacionar con asados sí o no
y con mi carne si uno quiere los
carnívoros si uno quiere son felices en
el verano si los carnívoros que si los
carnívoros quiere entonces louis
estuviste paseando te por ahí eso es una
localidad cercana a montreal que se
llama boozer bild que ha crecido
muchísimo en los últimos tiempos hay un
centro comercial del cual forma parte
ese local ese futuro local que estamos
viendo allí mejor dicho que se ha
inaugurado hace relativamente muy poco
tiempo con un complejo habitacional muy
grande tanto para gente mayor como para
gente del común familias con niños
inclusive y lo que me llama mi atención
es que entre uno de los negocios que
todavía no se ha habilitado pero que
como vemos ahí está pronto a hacerlo
está en pleno preparativo igual que los
gansos a los que se refería leonardo va
a haber una carnicería eso que ustedes
ven ahí es el cartel que anuncia que muy
se va a inaugurar allí una carnicería un
negocio de venta de carnes de carnívoras
y habla de [ __ ] exactamente de gente
que está orgullosa de ser carnívora así
que somos mucho la atención digamos no
es que me ofende ni mucho menos yo soy
carnívoro vengo de un país donde el
consumo de la carne es todo una traición
hasta que llegue a canadá podría decir
un poco exagerando pero un poco no de
que el 90 por ciento de mi alimentación
era prácticamente solamente carne ahora
está un poco más variedad es verdad pero
bueno me llamó mucho la atención sobre
todo en estos tiempos que corren cuando
los movimientos de vegetarianos y de
naturistas yo el otro día estaba en auto
me mandó un amigo mío que estaba en auto
o una foto de una patente ahora se le
puede poner ocho letras pues ponemos lo
que quiere la patente y dice vegana
la gente como que toma orgullo ahora en
grecia de los vegetarianos son
orgullosos también sí pero tampoco me
pareció mal que estuviera orgulloso este
carne como es que dice el cartel
y no me parece mal porque también es
cierto que no sé por qué razón cuando
una corriente de pensamiento o de o de
hábitos toma la delantera en algún
momento quienes no están a favor o que
están en la vereda de enfrente pasan a
ser entre comillas son tanto
discriminados vistos de mal ojo etcétera
entonces hoy en día hay mucha gente que
ve a quienes consumen carne de manera
que no me parece que va a ser así
tampoco digo que necesaria
bueno sobre todo porque se dijo
recientemente que tengo que cambiar
hábitos de consumo tal vez seguir
comiendo carne pero tal vez menos
la facturación que va a tener porque
está muy contenta pero bueno para los
que estén orgullosos de ser carnívoros
pronto el servicio de carnes la
carnicería del barrio abrirá a su poder
excelente me encantó me encantó el
cartelito exacto y siguiendo con temas
que también son de verano porque bueno
la gente como decíamos va a hacer asados
pero también va a viajar mucho y una de
las zonas que más es visitada en canadá
y bueno en quebec particularmente pero
en canadá en general es una es una
abstracción turística es ps y podemos
explicar en la región de la agasp es y
buscar un mapa para que la gente vea
bastante más que estaba digamos hacia el
norte sobre el río san lorenzo digamos
que el río san lorenzo divide la zona
este de canadá que de la que hablábamos
hace un momento la región de las
marítimas y luego a un lado entre entre
la zona de las marítimas y quebec está
el río san lorenzo y el río san lorenzo
sube hasta el atlántico hacia el norte
entonces bueno pérez está por allá
en la punta y no sé si podemos ver
y después en todo caso las fotos de
nosotros hicimos una escapada de casi
una semana con mi familia en una casilla
rodante y llegamos a perder después de
un largo viaje son aproximadamente 12
horas
desde montreal a per se y ahí bueno ese
es el camino entre el anterior en el
camino en realidad entre
y perdí per se porque gaste es como la
ciudad más conocida de esa región y en
la atracción turística
de eso que se llama horacio nava per se
porque verse es como agujereado y es una
gran roca gigantesca que está que tiene
un agujero para la perforación perfecta
por erosión por la erosión y nosotros
bueno nos fuimos hasta ahí o sea había
que meterse la agua y caminar lavó bien
fresquita y llegamos hasta la parte de
la perforación justamente de ese lugar
turístico que en realidad está preparado
para eso
de personas recorren ese lugar
viendo la piel perforada
barea dependiendo la marea si la marea
está baja uno puede pasar si la marea
está alta en realidad tampoco están tan
alta pero llega la larga la gente es la
gente porque la marea está baja y uno
puede cruzar del lado digamos cuando uno
está enfrente de la piedra del lado
izquierdo ahora en la otra foto queda
era 45 horas más tarde ya no se ve el
paso no se ven todas esas esa formación
rocosa que permite atravesar a taparse
bueno pues es un viaje que leonardo hizo
entonces por esa región de quebec
yo fui abitibi y también traje fotos de
la bici y que es una región de quebec
que está más hacia el oeste justamente y
que está más cerca de la frontera con
ontario
entonces yo fui por allá también tenemos
fotos de mi viaje a bit tv y vamos a ver
si las podemos ver
y lo que es lindo de la región es que
nadie va a ver lo contrario a per se
su apertura es muy turístico abitibi es
una zona donde poca gente va yo voy
porque la familia de mi marido va ahí en
una maleta y entonces ahí es donde yo
voy pero no es nadie
la mucha gente no visita ese lugar lo
bonito es que no hay nada más
hay mucha naturaleza y le decidió decir
la semana pasada 40 minutos de ahí está
el lugar nos la tienda más cercana para
ir a buscar comida entonces la pasé muy
bien tenemos fotos de que podemos
mostrar velocidad vayas pero un viaje a
vivir
miren vamos muy rápido con las fotos por
eso ya son otras fotos
esa es una foto de un evidentemente que
se lo encontramos en cualquier otra zona
la tomé porque mi hija siempre logra
encontrarlos
los animalitos más pequeños y los logra
atrapar en realidad nadie sabe pero es
un príncipe exacto
le damos un besito por filas y también
hay otras imágenes de sol pero y lo que
están tratando de conectarse con rinde
con la que teníamos la entrevista es un
momento y no podemos ver las otras
imágenes las otras fotografías bueno
aweys podríamos pasar a ver a ver el
vídeo de la aplicación de radio canadá
internacional a menos de que pierre nos
pueda mostrar no ok no sé qué vamos a
hacer el vídeo de la aplicación el vídeo
de la aplicación para invitar a la gente
a que nos que nos siga por la aplicación
también
le podemos encontrar en internet hace un
par de meses ya está disponible la
aplicación de radio canadá internacional
es una aplicación que tiene
características muy especiales y que
pone énfasis sobre todo en la producción
del equipo bueno de los cinco equipos no
del inglés francés español chino y árabe
que son los equipos que producen en el
sitio de internet de radio internacional
en el caso de la aplicación es muy muy
fácil de bajar en nuestro sitio de
internet arriba a la derecha hay una
pequeña publicidad que dice aplicaciones
ahí uno hace clic en ese lugar y va a
abrir una página donde nos va
directamente al enlace de las dos
boutique de aplicaciones más conocidas
android y apple así que ustedes pueden
hacer eso es realmente rápido y la
aplicación funciona muy bien y es muy
fácil de muy fácil manejo y con un toque
pueden estar mismo mirando esta emisión
en vivo desde la aplicación y justamente
también la gente nos puede seguir
facebook por facebook lite una página en
facebook no sé si habrá algún mensaje
por ahí en largo en nuestra página si
tenemos algún mensaje en facebook dame
dos segundos en este caso lado
echeverría nos dice saludos desde
aguascalientes en méxico laura si era
una amiga mía la novela es una amiga me
dice a mí me encanta como le dicen a la
gente de aguascalientes como es ya
cambiar cambiaron local ente éstas no
eran hidrocálidos
[Risas]
pero últimamente han querido y ya nos
dicen a los aguascalentenses
después jairo castillo decía saludos
desde maturín venezuela y daniel hosco
saludos para leonardo para mí desde san
luis argentina un saludo grande dan y
entonces a toda la gente que nos está
viendo en este momento
en esta transmisión en vivo de facebook
y tenemos por ahí otros mensajes
louis por ahí tenés de hecho tenemos uno
que me llama tiene usted de aquellas que
los mencionaremos por qué porque tiene
que ver con lo que acabamos de hacer que
es mostrar imágenes de distintos sitios
de canadá 10 o lugares que nosotros
recorremos habitualmente en esta vida
nómade que llevamos a cabo aquí y como
hacemos en todas las emisiones les
pedimos a nuestros oyentes a nuestro
público en general que nos hagan llegar
vídeos o fotos de los lugares en los que
residen para conocernos un poco más para
conocerlos de otra manera para no
solamente tener los mensajes por escrito
y en este caso nos dice
robinson mosquera dice hola saludos
desde colombia les escriben su amigo y
fiel radio escucha quiero participar de
sus programas pero a ser el reportero de
un día mi móvil es el número de su móvil
podría hablar de temas del proceso de
paz las drogas ilícitas y a veces del
gobierno colombiano en la erradicación
de cultivos ilícitos ilícitos perdón
esperó la llamada decir robinson ofrece
aquí hacer a través de un vídeo o de una
comunicación en directo sería este caso
pequeños contenidos sobre distintos
temas de su lugar en el que él vive del
país en el que él vive que es la
propuesta que nosotros reiteramos
continuamente ahora lo que sería
interesante es que robinson con esta
nueva dinámica que tenemos con la cámara
así con el estudio que nos envíe
fotografías tal vez si quiere colaborar
con y con sonido también lo pueden
enviar muy fácilmente tenemos un pool en
nuestro sitio internet pueden encontrar
el la direct el teléfono número de
teléfono al que nos pueden llamar y
dejarnos mensajes por audio y si nos
mandan vídeos o imágenes por correo
electrónico o por face
pues también podemos presentarnos al
mismo tiempo entonces quien quiera
participar en este segmento que antes
teníamos y que era muy muy bueno
fabulador no es muy popular si robinson
mosquera participó en el reportero de un
día varias ocasiones más es otra manera
de mostrar esa américa que es tan vasta
también siempre hablamos de la
diversidad que hay en lugares como en
canadá en eeuu en otros países que
también tienen territorios enormes
américa es un continente enorme vasto
diverso con cientos de tradiciones de
costumbres de hábitos que incluso uno
que viene de lugares en los que ha
tenido la posibilidad de intercambiar
con mucha otra gente a veces no conoce
supongo que el público habrá personas
que estén en la misma situación por qué
no usar las nuevas tecnologías para
facilitarnos a todos conocer un poco más
estaban hablando de las nuevas
tecnologías que ya no son tan nuevas
digamos
las tecnologías gabriel parada colin
dice saludos desde ese de mx si quiero
ser méxico
y mendizabal dice saludos desde praga
pero ya sabes gabriel lago laura a todos
que nos envíen vídeos de sus zonas para
que los podamos donde viven de sus
regiones de origen y ahí podemos
conversar con ellos bueno resulta que
logramos comunicarnos con nuestros
invitados ahora sí pero por teléfono
entonces vamos a hablar con ellos están
en por línea telefónica y manuel alberto
videla y carlos adrián zúñiga gonzález
como decíamos ambos profesores de
francés carlos en la ciudad de mexico y
en manuel alberto videla es en argentina
en buenos aires y ambos están en la
ciudad de monton participando en un
evento que es la tercera reunión de la
red de ciudades francófonas de las
américas y se llama particular el evento
en el que están ellos participando
movilización juvenil porque ellos son
jóvenes y es organizado por el sounds de
la francophonie des amériques o el
centro de la francofonía de las américas
carlos y emanuel como están ahora si nos
escuchamos
hola hola buenas tardes muy bien por
estar con ustedes nuevamente así lo
identificamos rápidamente con el acento
a emanuel y argentino de buenos aires
bueno estábamos hablando ese momento con
carlos y le hemos preguntado en realidad
preguntamos a ambos y carlos comenzó a
responder como dos jóvenes de ciudades
en las que se habla español se
convierten en expertos y en maestros de
francés karlos
bueno pienso que no es raro encontrar en
méjico personas que son seres en
aprender lenguas extranjeras pienso que
el francés es muy popular y a mí
personalmente me gustó mucho y pues
bueno mejor que mucho en conocerlo y al
día de hoy bueno trato de mejorar y no
perderla
y estamos viendo al mismo tiempo
imágenes de la fiesta de los saca de
anos que se anime en el marco dentro del
cual se está realizando esta reunión de
los de las ciudades francófonas de las
américas en manuel y tú por tu lado como
llegaste al mundo francófono a la
francofonía y en buenos aires
bueno también un poco como dijo carlos
es un poco gracias a la
a la actividad cultural lección desde
muy chicos desde los 8 años y una
publicidad donde se cantaba el francés y
le pregunté a mis padres se adquirió más
trabas me dijeron que era un placer y
pues más bien una motivación personal y
luego gracias a la escuela pública ya
las alianzas de la empresa que pude
seguir estudiando y luego continuar mi
información en institutos como el
lenguas vivas en donde forman
protectores de transfer y carlos decía
que no era muy raro encontrar gente en
méxico que hablara o se interesara en el
francés pero buenos aires y méxico que
tan franco folk a su banco filas o
francófonos son dirían ustedes
carlos
y la pregunta si lo que quiero decir que
quisiéramos saber es qué tan franco
filas o qué tan francófonas son las
ciudades en las que ustedes viven en tu
caso méxico cuánta gente no se conoce
cuánta gente pero quiero decir que tan
importante se ha vuelto el francés en la
ciudad de mexico
bueno particularmente en la ciudad de
mexico
hay instituciones que organizan varias
actividades
las que organizan muchas actividades de
difusión cultural y pienso que a nivel
universitario sobre todo a estar
creciendo mucho por la oferta que por
ejemplo en estos países como francia o
canadá ofrecen a los estudiantes para
para tener una movilidad hacia este país
y en tu caso manuel en buenos aires
bueno en buenos aires pese a que las
políticas que lleva a cabo el gobierno
de la ciudad no acompañan a la difusión
de la lengua extranjera sin expresar en
el francés es gracias a la escuela
pública y a las escuelas plurilingüe las
que existen en la ciudad qué
herramientas se difunde el francés tanto
para niños como adolescentes es una
realidad en la cual vivimos en donde el
francés te puede difundir tanto desde la
escuela pública que es gratuita y laica
para nuestra ciudad como también en la
provincia de buenos aires aun quedan
algunas algunas escuelas públicas y
algunos institutos en donde se pone en
valor y donde se disfruta la lengua no
como una lengua de uso instrumental sino
más bien como una lengua cultura una
lengua que nos puede incluir a todos
leonardo yo quería saber si sigue
funciona porque en argentina yo recuerdo
si la enseñanza del francés en las
escuelas públicas y también la la
presencia de una academia que estaba en
todo el país era la alliance française y
no sé si es es decir funciona igual en
méxico porque en realidad cursos de
inglés eran por todos lados por el
francés y estaba como
la entidad representativa oficial
digamos de la lengua por eso que se
tiene el cartel que tiene inclusive yo
me acuerdo cuando yo hice mi trámite
para venir a vivir a canadá y como
postulaba a través de la provincia de
québec había que pasar un examen en
francés y donde dice la formación claro
yo tenía una última pregunta para ambos
este evento en el que están participando
la el que se llama la movilización
juvenil de la red de ciudades
francófonos de las américas en qué
consiste en pocas palabras que están
participando ustedes
carlos manuel chincheta bueno es una
formación que está abierta
perfiles profesionales turismo
comunicación y disfrutamos de unos
talleres prácticos en los cuales tenemos
que hacer un proyecto que tiene que ver
dentro de nuestra especialidad y al
mismo tiempo
así que nos da conferencias ponencias
muy interesantes que hablan sobre la
cultura también
disfrutamos de eventos y con los demás
participamos también en eventos que
forman parte de la cultura y vida de la
celebración de la que la ley el 'gran
30ma que es como un gran líder o si
podemos traducir 30ma por ruido por
mucho ruido pero es como hacer ruido
mostrando al orgullo los vicios de los
sacar ya no si lo hacen cada año el 15
de agosto que es el día el día oficial y
emanuel tú por tu parte como como has
vivido este evento que tanto que tanto
te ha gustado o no es difícil me gusta
muchísimo de hecho es mi primera vez
también en en américa del norte y
específicamente en canadá y más
específicamente en montón realmente es
una experiencia inolvidable y batir y
nuclea bloques en francés pero realmente
es inolvidable porque no solamente es
una formación práctica en donde vamos a
tomar muchísimos de recursos que podemos
utilizar
clases sino que también es una formación
humana y reconocer las las otras
culturas reconocer que también existen
otras formas de hablar francés que
también podemos escuchar la riqueza de
los acentos y podemos encontrarnos con
el otro y podemos ir hacia el otro en un
diálogo mutuo
pues muchas gracias a ambos sé manuel
alberto videla de buenos aires y carlos
adrián su miga gonzález ustedes son
ambos profesores de francés en sus
ciudades de origen y están participando
en esta tercera reunión de la red de
ciudades francófonos de las américas por
parte del centro de la francofonía de
las américas en el marco del congreso
nacional acá dyens en las celebraciones
de los acá dientes y los órganos y los
actos en una próxima visita pero aquí en
montreal
gracias
hasta luego entonces y bueno nosotros
tenemos que hablar ahora porque no nos
queda mucho tiempo de los reportajes que
queremos poner de frente queremos
presumir y no no presumir
sí claro que nos parece importante
porque hacemos varios reportajes por
semana
y cada semana pedimos nos piden queremos
presentarles uno en particular
leonardo tú nos vas a hablar de ciencia
ficción que a ciencia ficción exacto y
es justamente lo que está presentando
este bueno ustedes lo conocen el alma y
para aquellos que no lo conocen es el
creador de empresas como paypal y
después se retiró y tesla y space ex
hiper loop son todas las empresas que
empezaron así como un sueño y una cosa
si bien de ciencia ficción y que
finalmente se concretaron pero ésta es
las ss lo más que es nacido en sudáfrica
y vive en eeuu y bueno resulta que tiene
un proyecto lo presentó el mes pasado es
un proyecto de un chip cerebral
conectarse con la inteligencia
artificial de la historia es qué
hay un montón de personas y estudiosos
de inteligencia artificial que están
tratando de recortar digamos cuáles son
las capacidades de la inteligencia
artificial porque tienen miedo de ellos
les llaman como el día x de la
inteligencia artificial que es cuando
esta inteligencia se apodera revela se
revele se apodera de la humanidad exacto
sí sí bueno y resultó que hay un montón
de gente que dice primero tiene que
llegar una cosa de estas de estas
características y segundo si llega
porque bueno es lo más dice que él está
pidiendo que esto pase que su proyecto
es para justamente evitar que la
inteligencia artificial tome control de
la humanidad entonces qué hacemos nos
metemos desde nuestro cerebro a la
inteligencia artificial eso es lo que
dice pero hay un montón de estudiosos de
cuestiones éticas y también con respecto
a la tecnología ética y diciendo que es
una locura
plantear detente y podríamos si llega a
acontecer es una locura así que bueno de
eso se trata más o menos de este nuevo
proyecto y de lo que es el chip cerebral
y de lo que esta gente dice
qué estás soñando con seguir facturando
facturas con paypal y bueno entonces
vamos a ver si se lo si se hace o no se
hace concretamente para los los mortales
como nosotros
lo pasa que su proyecto dice que en el
año 2020 es el primer ejercicio beasley
eso por ahí ayayay bueno entonces
sigamos en cosas más concretas por el
momento menos tecnológicas pero no menos
importante es la imagen impactó a más de
uno cuando el estadio olímpico de
montreal luis se convirtió digamos en un
gran centro de refugiados le fueron
llegando por la frontera de estados
unidos con las la provincia de québec y
bueno lo que cierto es que ahora según
un estudio de estadísticas canadá una
cantidad cada vez mayor de refugiados no
encuentra dónde instalarse donde vivir
en toronto todo el país y tiene que ver
y tiene que ver con ese fenómeno que vos
señalaba que se la llegada masiva de
refugiados de gente que provino de eeuu
que atraviesan la frontera a pie
cuando después de se instaló el gobierno
de donald trump en eeuu y por temor a
ser deportados salieron de ese país pero
no solamente con eso tiene que ver con
distintos componentes que está
adquiriendo este fenómeno de gente que
no encuentra techo en distintos lugares
del país y sobre todo en las grandes
ciudades ha habido un estudio que hace
la agencia canadiense de empleo y
desarrollo social que dice que en los
últimos meses ha subido muchísimo se ha
multiplicado esa cantidad de personas
que no consiguen un techo y esto tiene
que ver en algunos casos señala
específicamente el caso de la provincia
de ontario y más específicamente aún la
ciudad de toronto tiene que ver con los
recortes que se han hecho en planes
sociales debido al deseo del gobierno
local de asegurar un balance de sus
finanzas entonces ha recortado sus
planes sociales le ha quitado sustento a
organizaciones que trabajan con los
refugiados por ejemplo en el
acompañamiento en los trámites legales
que es un tema complejo que los
refugiados no pueden hacer por su cuenta
pero al mismo tiempo había una
degradación de la economía a partir de
la inflación y de la carencia
planes sociales que obliga a familias
que antes podían pagar de su bolsillo un
techo a recurrir a los refugios pensados
originalmente para la gente que no tiene
un techo propio entonces el espacio
mengua hay menos disponibilidad y hay
mucha gente que se ve como en el caso de
que yo cito en este en este material de
13 jóvenes recién llegados a toronto que
fueron descubiertos por una empleada de
una cadena de comidas rápidas durmiendo
durante tres noches en el local porque
no tenían a dónde ir y nadie se había
hecho cargo de ellos las agencias que
antes iban a buscar a los refugiados a
los aeropuertos y los acompañaban hasta
que podían comenzar a moverse por su
cuenta ya no pueden hacer ese trabajo
porque no tienen los fondos que le ha
quitado el gobierno provincial de
ontario y el gobierno de
toronto se está viendo también en
problemas arroyo esa misma situación así
que un tema que no siempre se le presta
demasiada atención y que se está
tornando cada vez más complejo en todo
el país no solamente contrario y no
solamente en todo que además está aunado
a toda la falta de vivienda accesible de
cualquier modo independientemente de que
sea refugiado
con solvencia que tiene distintas
aristas y una de ellas es precisamente
por ejemplo mirar esa de la vivienda en
todo el país en todo el país las además
hablaban mucho de la presencia muy con
muy muy intensa muy frecuente en las en
las regiones canadienses de empresas
como er bien vi y otras empresas que
rentan departamentos y que al final van
ocupando los espacios por si va a venir
una persona renta pero no lo hacen
accesible para la población del lugar lo
que tiene menos recursos se ven siempre
en el medio de la nada exactamente y
bueno entonces de este reportaje los dos
reportajes del mercado en línea mañana
por la mañana y el de luisa está ya
disponible en nuestro sitio internet y
tú y yo que les traigo yo que les traigo
porque este finde
a terminar el gran festival de la del
orgullo gay del orgullo el g/b
el lg vete q plus entonces en la ciudad
de montreal que es una ciudad con una
una digamos con mucha presencia física y
porque tenemos hasta un barrio en el que
se hace digamos presente y es se festeja
se celebra este orgullo el eje vete plus
entonces se lleva a cabo este festival
durante toda la semana esta semana de
agosto siempre la segunda la tercera
semana de agosto y el fin de semana va a
ver el desfile final y el museo de
bellas artes de montreal participa en
este festival del orgullo e invita a la
gente a visitar sus instalaciones y
además tienen su propio carro alegórico
es el cuarto año en el que el museo de
bellas artes se implica en este festival
del orgullo y lo que dice él natalia
natalie perdona tal y bonds el que es la
directora general y curadora
del museo que además habla muy bien
español es que forma parte este porque
este participar en este festival forma
parte de sus de sus ganas de las ganas
del museo de ser cada vez más diverso
más inclusivo y ser más representativo
de la sociedad porque el arte cree ella
puede crear puentes entre la gente
entonces toda la gente entonces utiliza
digamos el espacio del museo y la
vitrina del museo para hacer parte de
esta de esta inclusión y esta diversidad
de la que quiere hablar el museo bueno
pues eso les presento yo entonces
nuestro sitio internet www w punto eres
libre w
español w www triple w
bueno www.uned.es sea en español y no
podemos irnos sin hablar de woodstock
un saludo de sergio bullard hola saludos
desde porto alegre muchas gracias desde
brasil y tenemos ahí algunas imágenes de
woodstock que este año son 50 años se
cumple 50 años del evento que tenía que
comer ser chiquito y se hizo gigante que
fue un hito que fue creciendo porque
hubo una demanda mucho mayor de la que
los organizadores esperaban una demanda
de entrada me refiero de un evento para
80 60 mil personas más o menos terminan
habiendo no sé cuántas ahora ya son
excesivamente inundaron toda esa zona
del estado de nueva york se convirtió en
un hito realmente cultural quien nos
recuerda la figura de richie havens
cantando con su guitarra freedom
libertad que es uno de los iconos de ese
festival que contó con muchísimas
figuras de renombre y que abrió las
puertas a los grandes eventos del rock
junto con el festival a beneficio de
bangladesh que en su momento organizó
george harrison en los eeuu en el
madison square garden que fue en ese
caso el primer evento benéfico
del rock and roll en el mundo justo
quien es ya su lugar en la historia su
lugar en la música y para los amantes
del rock más puro valió la pena volver a
ver los viejos vídeos de ese festivo y
en ese vídeo que estábamos viendo pues
presentaban a artistas de quebec y
artistas de canadá que estaban presentes
que estuvieron presentes durante el
festival y era una celeste vídeo
mostraba digamos gusto gusto con estos
artistas 20 años después de haber
participado en el evento no sé si tú
tengas algún recuerdo específico no 72
así que no
conozco de woodstock porque la gente
sigue hablando hasta el día de hoy
y cómo se ha tratado durante todo el
paso del tiempo y en la historia de no
rehacer pero de hacer cosas similares a
gustos y no se logró si bien han habido
porque pro rock in río fue este tipo de
evento es aquello fue un evento social y
es un evento social como tal en ese
sentido no se puede reproducir el
festival de gusto que le puso el broche
de oro a lo que fue la era del flash del
flower power en eeuu y eso no se puede
recrear porque era todo un sentimiento
solista y de todo lo demás que vino
después también bueno pues ya se nos
acabó el tiempo ahora sí yo siempre
estamos corriendo un poco siempre al
principio del programa pero al final se
nos acaba el tiempo y se acabó el tiempo
yo quería solo resaltar que la semana
pasada nos olvidamos hablar del día del
orgasmo que fue el orgasmo femenino de
la semana pasada sólo había notado y lo
pasé de largo en un mes anotaciones que
entre nos trae a las efemérides y ahora
eso es bueno
y tiene un porqué nació en brasil bueno
ya ves entonces con otras efemérides
también pero bueno muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado esto fue todo por
canadá en las américas café de este fin
de semana que 10 o el 16 17 y 18 vamos a
decir que este fin de semana esos son
esos tres días entonces gracias por
habernos acompañado allá en los
controles técnicos pierna útil calculan
si no hay hogar aquí en el estudio
leonardo si menor luis laborda y paloma
mantilla chao
[Música]
aquí